yes that happens and so I understand all
that that all makes sense so what's
what's the question you're looking at
the past but I struggle so hard with my
answer to my you know like I can handle
it
so it's either coming it's coming from
one or two places it's cut you're
allowing somebody else to judge you or
you're judging yourself I'm telling you
the number one thing that fascinates me
about people is they take the past and
give it so much credit and they
underestimate the current in the future
you're looking dead in the face of
getting results yet the fear of the
replication of something that happened
before is stopping you from going so I
think this is about making a decision
and not dwelling or pondering on what if
because what-ifs crippled people you
will regret not going for it
way more than if you fail a second time
everybody here right now can sit here
and say what if about something I should
have stuck with Paul I should have
invested in face but like good you know
like what if scared look you gotta be so
taking action is especially if it
doesn't cost you top money and it's just
time is always a better answer than
pondering or thinking or trying to
decide if this is gonna work you don't
know the learning of the failure is is
equal to the victory of it I'd rather
lose again like I like what you can lose
your how you like you know like people
are scared of things that aren't real
people are scared of things that are not
real it can life
like nobody knows what's gonna happen
tomorrow so how do you I'm sorry it's
all right good by recognizing I have no
choice
you guys got love for each other in
those three kids you could be in
homeless and happy you could you could
you could I mean we don't might not feel
I feel it might be better but like like
I'm just trying to ask people what
they're scared I've been what they're
scared of if they go all the way to the
core is other people's opinions by not
worrying about what other people think
it allows you to do things by doing
things you either win or you learn from
your loss and it creates speed it's the
absolute mental difference between the
people that are executing a winning
versus the people that aren't it's the
fear of others I don't want to lose but
I'm definitely more disappointed than
your opinion in your blog post about my
loss I'm just looking at you to like
their love that's good so guess what
you're in a [ __ ] place what do you
need what do you want you need Netflix
Netflix what do you need you need like
I'm confused by people creating these
fake frameworks and so I navigate happy
because I'm just grateful for what I
have and other people have more other
people s when I had a whole lot less I
was happy with I had then I just
everyday recognized that if I'm in my
own head and realized that everybody's
got their own do then I don't spend time
complaining and dwelling I spend time on
doing you wouldn't be scared if you
realize the worst-case scenario is it'd
be worse
there'd be three of you right but like
what like I'm telling you right now
those kids are not gonna lose if you
guys are losing it's gonna make them
stronger they all have different
personalities but if you're instilling
the right values and showing them love
they're gonna win I'd much rather have
loving parents that were homeless and
still bad
than successful parents that were doing
the wrong thing I'm gonna have a better
life that's been proven people are
scared of other people's judgement
people are scared of other people's
judgement right what are people gonna
think if we lose our home or we lose
again you're pondering you lack the
confidence because you're worried about
what people say I like losing that's why
this is all so easy give up if you said
I lost man I'm telling you
rocky six I think that's the one where
he went back to the big right when he
lost everything that was my it wasn't a
good movie and that's my favorite one
because he went back to zero and it's
not that scary who you're scared
instead security insecurities poison
massive poison
stop looking backwards it's just uh it
will slow you down to where you're going
[Music]
you